driving on a on a tight circle above
runoff is very very different from
driving on the circus that most people
raised on tracks with closed faces
besides the narrow tracks is y'all so
they're highly sensitive speed
everything's ramped up the fear factor
the excitement adrenaline everything is
just magnified you just know that you
can't afford to make any kind of mistake
trying a little bit too hard and
spinning the car
seeing the walnut ever ever subside
through the witness frame didn't it it
was very close the first time you really
don't fit in a supercar is always a
memorable experience but one of the best
things is that all supercars have got
very different characters a really
powerful rear-wheel drive car is going
to be a bigger challenge to me perhaps
only four wheel drive and that's what
makes it exciting
it's the relentlessness of the
acceleration usually you can be in
conventionally fast cars it feels good
for a short period I think the exciting
with a supercar something that much
power that it never quite feels like
it's tailing off there's nothing better
really when you're a car fan you know to
get up on the wheel or something that's
it's very quick the sensation just
acceleration and and grip and cornering
it's it's yeah Racing is exciting and if
you can accurately replicate that in the
game it's going to be exciting I've
don't think there's any need to really
over complicate it I think if you get an
honest sense of what it's like to be
racing against other people in cars then
drop down